we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p
we talked earlier in the show about
vaccine alarmism which is different than
antivax anti-vax is also a big problem
from the standpoint of the coronavirus
vaccine
here is a caller who sounds like he's in
a really tough situation with his
parents at home take a listen to this
hi david this is christian from baton
rouge louisiana
i was just wondering if you could speak
on
the safety of the vaccine because
my parent who's a clinical physician
has pretty much told
me that if i take the vaccine that they
won't talk to me
wow because they're so scared of it and
i mean practically everyone i know
is not taking the vaccine out of fear
that
it's rushed or that it's gonna hurt them
i just i don't see how doctors can think
this
and it not be true it is very
scary that many health care workers
including doctors and nurses
are uncritically repeating some of the
same
debunked derogatory talking points about
the vaccine
that people who you know do research by
looking at the articles shared by their
crazy
cousin on facebook uh every single one
of these claims has been debunked
the vaccine wasn't rushed the mrna-based
platform for making vaccines
has been in play for more than a decade
at this point and
part of it is that once you have the
platform in place
the individual vaccine takes far less
time to develop so that's
one piece that's been answered the
question about
vaccine safety there uh i actually i
have an exchange with an anti-vaxxer
that i might publish soon via via email
um but one of the talking points that
they talk about is
someone died during vaccine testing and
what they are referring to is an
individual
in brazil who died of covet
complications while part of the vaccine
trial
it was later determined that they were
in the placebo group
that individual did not even receive
the vaccine very important to understand
and then in terms of long-term effects i
mean listen we've talked about this
before
you can always say there might be some
effect
over a time period that is longer than
the time period the vaccine has been out
if a vaccine has been out for 20 years
you could always say we don't know if
the vaccine doesn't have negative
long-term effects
that you only learn about after 21 years
if a vaccine's been out 50 years you can
say
what if the negative effects start after
51 years
what we do know uh is that
the um negative effects that are known
about vaccines
tend to happen within the first couple
of weeks and that is it
and that historically there was a
vaccine
a long time ago that over the long term
increa increased your
risk of um being diagnosed with
guillain-barre syndrome and i believe it
changed it from a one in two million to
one in one
million uh that is an old vaccine i'm
going from memory i believe it was an
early polio vaccine although i may be
wrong about that please don't hold me to
it
and we know a lot about these things so
it's scary that a doctor is telling
their kid
if you get vaccinated i won't talk to
you unfortunately
the virus of antivax has infected
many areas of american society and
that's a very
very scary thing but hopefully anti-vac
sentiment will decline
it has been declining at one point in
may of 2020
60 percent of the country said they
weren't interested in the covet vaccine
that dropped to 50 40 30. latest numbers
i saw are that about a quarter
of the country doesn't want the vaccine
and the number keeps declining with time
that's good and hopefully as vaccine
supply becomes available
vaccine interest will also increase
we've got a great bonus show for you
today california
is going with their own coveted relief
package very interesting we will discuss
it
we also have new obstacles to the
confirmation of joe biden's nominee nira
tandon this is a nominee i opposed from
day one
and now it is actually looking like more
and more of an uphill battle for near
attendant thanks to a couple of
republicans that's a good thing
i'll tell you why and lastly treasury
secretary
janet yellen has sounded a warning about
bitcoin we will talk about that and much
more
on today's bonus show get instant access
by becoming a member
at joinpakman.com